hello everyone a lot of you said you
would like to see some more games from
my chess club championship this is the
game I played today I played against my
brother-in-law got an Arctic this is
like the I don't know maybe 15th time
we're playing since every year we meet
in our chess club championship and this
year I got the white pieces so we played
a lot of games me and him and I really
had no idea what to prepare for this
game I did to check up on some of the
Italian game openings and I checked some
Scandinavians as I thought he might
employ us but in the end he managed to
avoid my opening preparation entirely so
I had the white pieces and I opened the
game with efore and he played c5 he went
for the Sicilian defense I played a
night of 3d six I went d4 see captors
Knight captures Knight to f6 Knight to
c3 and a6 he went for the knight of
variation and as he played all of his
moves relatively quickly like in a
second or maybe two seconds I know that
he definitely prepared something so I
wasn't sure do I want to go for maybe
Bishop to g5 do I want to go for Bishop
to e2
I thought he whatever I'd play he
probably has something prepared for it I
went for Bishop to c4 as I thought this
might be something he didn't look into
but in the end he probably did he played
east 6 and I played Bishop but back to
b3 simply not not to all-out any any
ideas maybe Knight captures on e4 and
then pushing d5 not immediately but at
some point Bishop to b3 always a useful
move
he played Knight B to d7 and here I
castled here I really thought it'd be
funny if he played something like Bishop
to e7 if he plays Bishop to d7 here then
I can freely capture this pawn Bishop
captures and if he can't I mean of
course we either capture or you're down
upon the knight captures attacking the
Queen and after the Queen moves I could
simply grab on g7 with check King moves
and after Knight to a5 is he just lost
three pawns here for a piece so
basically the material
is equal one piece for three pawns but I
messed up his King and it's a better
position for white but of course he
didn't go for this after I canceled he
played Knight the c5 and that's a useful
move both of his Knights are now
pressuring my e4 pawn he can take my
light square bishop which is a very
strong Bishop whenever he chooses so
there definitely a good position for
black
I played rook to e1 defending d4 pawn
and he played Queen to c7 and here I
played Bishop to g5 Bishop to g5 isn't
the best way to continue this position
better would be something like a three
or maybe even a four but okay I went for
Bishop to g5 and here after giving the
position some consideration he played b5
and b5 I I knew it was a mistake I
didn't know I rather I felt it was a
mistake better would be something like
Bishop to e7 and then the game continues
but he played b5 and after he played
this I thought about two ideas my first
idea was Bishop captures on f6 followed
by Knight to d5 my second idea was
Knight to d5 immediately and after
thinking about these ideas
I played Knight to d5 immediately which
is white is still better here but this
move is the far worse than capturing the
knight first the reason is the reason is
if you ever find yourself in this
position if black who goes with this
early b5 you want to capture the knight
first with Bishop captures and only
after G captors you want to go Knight to
d5 now attacking the Queen and c7 and
also attacking the f6 pawn so he doesn't
really have a good way of replying to
this you can't really defend the f6
point if you play Queen to d8 you'll get
Knight to c6 and then white is winning
so probably something like Queen to b7
or he can simply capture it but even if
Queen to b7 then you just grab the pawn
and you mess up you mess up the King's
position and then you're simply winning
this game but the idea is after Knight
to d5 what if he captures well it
captures now then after he captures this
comes with a check and now he has to
play Bishop to e7 and this is different
than from the line I played with the 95
immediately you can't do something like
King to d7 because of Queen to h5 now
going for the f7 pawn and you can't
prevent white capturing after Bishop e7
Queen captures and after you block this
with the rook now comes Knight to c6
there's a triple attack here on the
bishop and black is falling apart here
so after this b5 move which he played
better is this ideas so captures and
then Knight to d5 but I played Knight to
d5 immediately and the problem with 95
immediately is that now the knight can
be actually captured for example he can
capture it and after I capture back with
check now as this Knight is still in the
game now he has the option of going
night after e4 blocking my check and I
do win a piece back with f3 but he does
have time to consolidate h6 maybe Bishop
to h4 Bishop to e7
now characters capture and after F
captures on e4 it's still a better
position for white white is up a pawn
but black and simply castle and the game
continues
White's still being better but not not
as much better as a white would like to
be better
so after b5 if you're ever in this
situation do play Bishop captures on f6
first okay I played Knight to d5 and
here he decided to play Knight captures
on b5 I played pawn captures on d5 and
here he played 'if I've of course he
can't open D file immediately but he
doesn't want me to open it either and I
played f4 immediately I want to open the
file no matter what here he played
Knight captures on b3 which there really
is there's really no need to do this as
my bishop isn't really doing all that
much aside from okay he's protecting the
d5 pawn and maybe that Bishop can become
an active piece in the future but for
now there's really no reason to capture
this I move like f6 gives gives black a
solid position and
white is still better but you you have
to you have to keep playing this game so
here keep late night captures and I
played see capture some b3 maybe even a
character some b3 is better but I
thought okay I will capture away from
the center but at least I get a C file
for my rook as the queen is occupying
the C file and momentarily so he played
Bishop to e7 and again here f6 would
have been a more solid defense but okay
Bishop to e7 and here I played rook to
c1 first bringing my rock into the game
with the tempo on the Queen I he played
Queen to d7 and now Bishop captures
Queen captures and bomb captures on e5
and here he castled you can't grab the
pawn here because if pawn captures the
knight to c6 attacking the Queen and the
pawn and after the Queen moves rope
captures and if I would check you have
to move the King and you just you still
I still grab back the pawn and now he
didn't even castle so this is this is
winning for white so after this F
captors on e5 he decided to castle and
now I played Knight to c6 here probably
a move like Queen to d7 Queen to c7
protecting the the d6 pawn is something
black wants to do here but he decided to
go Queen to h4 I thought he just wants
to give up another point to maybe play
Bishop to g4 activating his bishop but
after I captured he didn't go for this
Bishop to g4 although okay Bishop to g4
I seem to play Queen to d4 and it's all
it's all fine for white but instead
after he captures on d6 he played Queen
back to f6 now with the idea of going
after the d6 pawn but now white is
winning by force in this position in
this position I seem to play Knight to
e7 check King to h8 and now I simply
grab the bishop on c8 Knight captures he
has the capture back
I played rook captures on c8 rook
captures on c8 and here I push to d7
of course the threat is rook to e8 check
he played rook to f8 he has to block
this and I
it rook to e8 all the same and it was in
this position position that he resigned
the game as he can capture it if he
captures them it's checkmate and any
other move he plays I will simply play
d8 and promote my pawn to a queen and
it's over for example to g8 the edge
Queen and now captures captures it's all
the same or you know he could capture
for example with the Queen but then if
she captures captures its Queen against
rook again winning for white so yeah
that's the game I played today I do hope
you enjoyed it and you know what's the
moral of this story I play it I play the
opposition that I don't know and at this
moment that he played b5 I felt it was a
mistake but I didn't really know how to
punish it so better would be to simply
to simply grab this for example Bishop
captures and only after he recaptures
with GG actress now do I play 95 and
after he captures it for example
captures captures now Bishop to e7 and
now it's a totally different story now I
can go Knight to c6 and this is
something that I saw in my calculations
but then you have to take into
consideration this Bishop to e6 move and
you have to know that if pawn captures
then after Queen captures Bishop here
sorry Queen captures knight on c6 and
now you have pawn captures on f7 with
check King to d8 and now Bishop to d5
and that this is winning for White Queen
moves the Bishop captures Queen captures
and now black does have two point two
pieces for the rook but it's a
completely lost position for black and I
guess from as of today I will know this
but in that position I decided to go
Knight to d5 immediately instead of
capturing on f6 first because now
although it does seem like black does
have compensation and that at some point
he will maybe have the open G file but
not really
for example before kicking the night
away Knight moves now Queen to d2
threatening Queen captures Queen
characters bishop there's no way for you
to actually activate the rook
mhm 8 because pawn is covering g8 and eh
so after Knight to e5 you can simply go
a for you want to break open the
position and after black does finally
decide to go for that f1 I'll simply
play a capture some b5 rook captures and
now you push f4 Knight moves and now
rook captures an a6 and black is
completely falling apart here
Queen d7 you can play c4 and it's only
white that will choose how to win this
position where it will be Queen to a2
followed by Queen rook to a7 rook e8 and
maybe he will double up the other work
on da file this is a this is the
position you get if if black pushes b5
too early and you play correctly but I
didn't I didn't see so far and I decided
maybe Knight d5 was a better move
because I thought my bishop on g5 will
only be a useful piece I don't have to
capture on f6 if he moves the knight and
then my bishop will be slicing all the
way to the 8th this can only be good but
in the end I played a lesser move and if
my opponent my brother-in-law defended
correctly you know he would give me that
definitely giving me a hard time and you
know in the end he might even have won
this game so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it you know know your
openings you'll save yourself a lot of
trouble as usual you can check to my
previous videos here I would like to
thank Stephen Marlowe Philip triking
Andrew liftin burger and Nels Lindberg
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here I already said that still
taking suggestions what do you want for
my 100,000 subscribers giveaway video
probably I will reach it in a couple of
days so do make plans for next Friday or
Saturday I will make an announcement
there will be a stream as usual picking
of the winners the rules will be given
to you in some video before that so I
will keep
all informed so yeah thank y'all for
watching and I will see you soon